based on everything we've been talking
about today I've changed my mind on how
the shattering happened and how everyone
obtained their great rooms I've changed
my mind based on the article we read and
some more information here so I'm
open-minded man I just want to know
what's going on
I want to fully understand this game
because I feel like my brain is all over
the place with it and it frustrates me
to a point of where when I'm making
content I am not fully confident in the
things that I'm saying so I'm very much
willing to change my mind on things that
I thought were true for the longest time
yeah I don't care what the truth is I
just want to know what the truth is
exactly
yeah we're we're having a very in-depth
discussion on that because a lot of
people think very differently on what
the shattering actually is and what it
means it's very conflicting for people
it is based on the conversation we were
having yesterday I'm not sure I don't
really know some people think that the
demigods obtain their great runes after
Queen America shattered the Eldon ring
so she shattered it all the runes burst
off into different directions and all of
the demigods picked up the great runes
after the shattering and then the
shattering War started what I believe to
be true
is that Queen America gave each of her
children their own great rune to
weakened the Elden ring and then broke
the Elden ring and then shattered the
Elden ring and then that insinuated the
shattering War as well there's the
shattering war and then there's the
shattering of the Eldon ring people are
very conflicted in that because the
wording here is confusing this was their
argument is that the narrator says that
the great Elden ring was shattered and
then it goes into everything else
so people think that what the narrator
is saying here is in order
which it I don't believe it is I think
that's the main theme of the game
the Elden ring was shattered here's how
it all led to that is basically what the
intro is saying here in the night of
black knives Godwin the golden was first
to perish so he was the first demigod
to die tell me if I'm right or wrong
here I'm just gonna put this out here
let me know if you think it's right or
wrong Queen America had Godwin morgot
and Moog Godwin died in the night of
black knives to Ronnie unbeknownst to
most people I believe and then Queen
America gave her Offspring the rest of
her children their own great runes as
well Godwin is like one of the first
in the era of like Moog and morgot as
well but Mogan wargot turned out to be
almonds so I'm assuming they didn't get
their great runes at first but they did
obtain their great runes after some
other demigods in their line
died
and then they obtained them they stole
them kind of like godric did I don't
know if it's stealing or they
somehow that we don't know for sure it
it's possible
that morgot and Moog obtained their
great runes during the War I think that
is possible because I do think that's
the main purpose for the war itself was
all of these demigods had their own
great runes they all had their own they
all had their own aspirations they all
had their own goals a lot of them didn't
want to be a part of the golden order at
all so they they fought for for power
essentially runes can be created and not
just by demigods though gold Mass via
dung eater we all have a rune that gets
added to the Elden ring with those for
different endings well yes those are
mending runes if we want to amend the
Elden ring in a particular way we have
to go through their quest lines to do so
yes there is a difference between great
runes and mending runes
that is true and then there's the the
runes that we find all over the world
the runes that you collect to upgrade
your character uh things like that those
are not great runes they're just runes
that you can obtain power from there are
lots of different kinds there's like the
Newman ruins and the Lord runes and
um just the the golden runes that give
you different amounts of runes
themselves he even describes what he's
talking about in the previous Slide the
Mad scene of their Newfound strength
triggered the capital S shattering and
then very slowly goes into a war
from which no Lord arose
explaining what it is yeah it's driving
me crazy too zombie I want to figure
this the [ __ ] out give the narrator's
words it seems that as the Elden ring
was shattered the great rooms were
cleaned by the demigods and they gained
Newfound strength the Newfound implies
they were not given the runes that's a
good point so it was the big Miyazaki
interview summer of gaming this was in
June of 2021. I was hoping that you
could kind of Define some terms that we
were just made aware of by the trailer
the player character is known as a
tarnished and can you explain what the
Elden ring is and the significance of it
being shattered
that's money okay in the world of Elden
ring the Lance between are blessed by
the presence of the Elden ring and by
the ERD tree which symbolizes its
presence the the Earth tree itself and
this has given Grace or blessing to the
people throughout the land Great and
Small what this represented in them is
this sort of golden light or this golden
aura that specifically shown in their
eyes and this symbolizes the blessing or
the grace of the earth tree however
after a time there were some individuals
who lost this grace and the light faded
from their eyes and these are what are
known as the tarnished that's pretty
much everything we already knew so the
tarnished you could call them tarnished
individuals who have lost Grace this was
a long time preceding the setting of The
Game a long time before a long time he
just says a long time the ancestors of
the characters that are present in the
world were vanished and exiled from the
lands between these tarnished then a
long time after that the Elden ring was
shattered in a historical event this
triggers the return of this lost Grace
and it calls out to the tarnished who
were once exiled from the lands between
and it guides them back so this is the
starting point or the impetus of the
game itself the tarnish being called by
the Lost Grace and returning to the
lands between
I feel like one of the main themes of
the game is how the player the tarnished
approaches or treats this newfound Grace
and this return to the land that they
were once banished from how they
interpret this and the meaning so that
yeah that's what I've been saying for a
long time it's like each ending you get
is based on your own personal Journey
it's not just the player character of
course it's lots of characters in the
game Who are all beckoned back and will
have their own adventures and motives we
want the player to discover for
themselves what that means and how they
want to begin their Adventure so we we
know that the tarnish are considered
people who lost Grace obviously this is
IGN asking Miyazaki another question one
of the things that really struck me in
the trailer was the enemy designs some
of the wildest designs I've ever seen
really I wonder if there's any sort of
unifying theme or inspiration that you
use when coming up with the enemies and
the bosses for this game and if you can
elaborate a little bit about them I'm
glad you picked up on that there's
several themes to the enemy designs one
main theme of the main bosses of the
game in particular are that they are
essentially demigods and characters who
are written Again by George RR Martin
and they inherited the Mad tainted power
of the Eldon ring shards once it was
shattered there it is
we wanted to depict these beings as not
just creatures in horrible monsters but
have an element of her heroism and an
element of Mythology to them essentially
they are the old gods of this world I
mean chat when it comes to the
shattering here I'm going to believe the
creator of the game you know
I I know it might lead to some different
things in the game itself Here If
Miyazaki is gonna say
that the demigods obtained their great
rooms from the shattering itself I'm
gonna believe that unfortunately I think
I've been told by so many people that
that's not how the shattering worked and
how they obtained their great runes that
I just believed something else
that sucks man based on everything we've
been talking about today
I've changed my mind
on how the shattering happened and how
everyone obtained their great rooms I've
changed my mind based on the article we
read and some more information here yeah
I think Queen America shattered the
Elden ring for all of the reasons that
we've talked about for months now like
all the potential reasons she shattered
it all of the shards spread out
everywhere and all the demigods obtained
the power from it so I'm open-minded man
I just want to know what's going on
I want to know I want to fully
understand this game because I feel like
my brain is all over the place with it
and it frustrates me to a point of where
when I'm making content I am not fully
confident in the things that I'm saying
so I really want to I want to understand
this damn game man so I'm very much
willing to change my mind on things that
I thought were true for the longest time
yeah I don't care what the truth is I
just want to know what the truth is
exactly yes I I know fully understand
and soulsborne games don't really work
together I do think that I can be
confident in the major aspects though
because right now I'm not and for me to
make good content like I know I can I
have to fully understand what's going on
made in the lands of the Newman outside
the lands between the tool with which
Queen America shattered the Elden ring
and radagon attempted to repair it that
still could mean
that he is repairing it into something
else that's a good point the ring wasn't
really shattered only some shards come
out the ring does remain attack in the
end press one and chat if this game is
confusing I've never really thought of
radagon trying to mend the Elden ring in
a different way instead of trying to fix
it back to exactly what it was before
do you guys think that radagon in
America were in it together
to break the Elden ring
to shatter it okay we're pretty much all
saying no to that I agree I don't think
radagon really wanted any of this to
happen I do think he tried to fix
everything before all of it went down
and he failed and now he's just a
[ __ ] puppet
and queen America knew that she would be
in prison for what she did
she knew she would be in trouble and
she's clearly in trouble radagon is just
a puppet by the greater will so I'm
assuming that they used radagon's
physical form to imprison America right
and it's his sigil that's a good point I
didn't I didn't think about that either
so this is radagon Seal so so that tells
us that the greater will has used
radagon to just
keep Queen America in the tree here guys
I think we I think we answered our
question I think we answered what we
wanted to this stream I wanted to know
how the shattering started and I think I
have come to a decisive conclusion to
that which I don't think we've ever done
in a lore hunting stream before so claps
and chat it's a community effort it's a
community conversation so that's all of
us not just me which I find so much more
entertaining than me doing this yes the
the guidance of Grace known to us by
Queen America in the erdry and radagon
being controlled by the greater will
for us to show guidance of Grace as
Godfrey fights us like me just reading a
script and I'm just like
like at least this is a little different
you know what I mean so which answer are
you taking away for the night Jake we
already said it but the shattering War
and the shattering itself was started by
Queen America shattering the Elden ring
all of the shards dispersed
um and everyone in the lands between was
fighting for power and the strongest
obtained the the great runes that they
have let's [ __ ] go